qui coulait bangers déjà le quatrième du
tos de l'ader modem si quelque chose me
dit que vous allez devenir des vrais
petits dancing machine et peut-être
qu'ils s'aiment avoir un corps comme ça
regardez ça fait rêver
je comprends aller j'ai dit les boys
qu'est ce que c'est que ça qu'est ce que
tu fais là toi non je suis pas un boss
mais je fais là de leur modèle je
m'entraîne depuis des mois cette
playmate
qu'est ce que j'en ai à [ __ ] que tu
veux faire c'est pas l'armée du salut tu
es gentil presque chacun boys camille
ok les filles quand vous serez faire ça
vous serez les boys en attendant up du
ballet août merci beaucoup
soré pour cette perte de temps ça
m'énerve de leurs modèles ce et on
commente le garçon avec leur tournée
agacé a alors on regarde loin devant et
sexy on avance un petit peu et là
nouveau pas c'est le cléopâtre d'une
aube à attention propre il profite bien
le bassin way profil profil comme
facebook et encore profil bravo didon
c'est bien j'aime ce que je vois je vois
ce que j'aime mais attention pas suivant
le flamant rose sept tours aux commandes
est pas morose
eh bien il est sur une jambe il sera pas
un peu fatigué d'être toujours sur une
jambe ce flamand changements john
changement d'homme avec les hells angers
dans ce sens je dorme pour bravo il est
heureuse flamants roses mais ce qu'ils
n'avaient pas vu en cherchant l'amour
c'est qu'un vilain chasseur était dans
le coin et pan il tombe il me dit
malheur mais dense il est toujours
heureux bien sûr bravo les vols près de
l'art moderne
maintenant je vois tout le monde debout
et toute la france dans ces lieux
bonjour et basel loti un petit nouveau
comme ils s'appellent celui je t'échange
et actions boys et ben walker jean
jacques et welcome chez vous vous êtes
prêt d'honneur modèle 1
3 musique
yeah bravo les boys bravo les nouveaux
et bravo à vous chez vous et qui sait
peut-être un cinquième tuto ce delà de
leurs modèles